VectorDrawable has been
introduced in Android Lollipop
release for one year.
We are getting many feedbacks
that a good tool is needed
for the developers to create
assets for VectorDrawable
and use them for older
Android versions.
Hi, this is Tenghui from
Android UI Toolkit team.
I'm happy to give you an update
on our latest tool support
to adjust those concerns.
In Android Studio 1.4, we
introduce a new tool for you
to either easily pick one vector
asset from material design icon
library or convert your own
SVG files into your vector
drawables.
Moreover, you can use
this vector asset even
when you are building
against pre-Lollipop release
without any code change.
That is very cool, right?
First, let's dive
into the new UI
we introduced in
Android Studio 1.4.
If you right click on any
photos in your application,
you will see one menu
options call New.
Click that.
You will see one sub-menu
called Vector Asset.
Click that.
You will be able to see this new
Vector Asset Studio dialogue.
Assuming right
now, you just want
to pick one existing vector
asset from material design icon
library, then you just
click this Choose button.
Then, you would see a
dialogue with all the asset
in the library.
Now, simply just pick one
you like, then hit OK.
Now, you would see a nice
preview for this vector asset.
If you are happy
with how it looks,
then just go ahead
and hit Next button.
Otherwise, there
are some options
on the top right
off this dialogue.
For example, you can change
its width and height,
and you can modify
the translucency
of the whole asset, or
add auto-mirroring support
for right to left language.
Note that auto-mirroring
support is only for version 21
and above.
In some other cases, if I just
want to use your own SVG files,
then please click this radio
button set, Local SVG File.
Then you would be able
to open a file browser,
pick your own SVG
files, then you
will be able to see
the preview showing up.
Given SVG is a huge
spec and often contains
many redundant
information, although we
will continue to improve our
tool to support more SVG files,
currently, we don't support
all of the features in our tool
yet.
If we find anything in your
SVG file that we don't support,
we will be report it as
an error at the bottom.
Please look into the
details of the error message
and simplify your SVG files
and try to import again.
Or, if you're happy with
the generated preview,
then feel free to
go to the next page.
You will see an SML file
with a preview showing up
in your res slash
drawable directory,
and you only need to check
in this simple SML file
into your [INAUDIBLE].
Hit the Finish button now.
Then the vector asset will be
successfully generated for you.
Now, I will describe how the
backward compatibility works
and its current limitation.
First of all, if
your app is targeted
for Lollipop or newer versions,
then the full API spec
is supported.
Feel free to modify and
use the vector drawable
according to the spec.
However, we know many of you are
developing on older platforms.
In order to support
older platforms which
don't have VectorDrawable,
we have some limitations
I will mention later.
Our [INAUDIBLE] system
would generate a PNG asset
automatically for you.
Here's how this automatically
generated assets looks like.
After you build an app, if you
switch to the Project View,
you would notice there's
a directory called PNGs
under the generated directory.
Under this PNGs
directory, you will
see familiar drawable
directories with different APIs
and version numbers.
In simple cases, you will
see a pair of directory
for one particular DPI, like
here-- one xxxhdpi directory
containing the PNG file
and correspondingly
a xxxhdpi version
21 directory which
contains a copy of the
vector drawable's SML file.
This file structure
enables the build system
to pick up the vector drawable
for SDK version 21 and above
while falling back to PNG
files for older versions.
There are some
limitations where we
are dealing with this backward
compatibility support.
We are trying our
best to show the link
errors in the vector drawable's
SML file for these limitations.
First, only a subset of API
features of VectorDrawable
are supported.
We are enhancing this now, but
currently, group and click path
text are not supported, given
we can only have one static PNG
file generated to replace
VectorDrawable in older Android
version.
That also means in the SML
file of VectorDrawable,
we cannot support dynamic
attributes such as theming
or auto-mirroring.
And for performance concerns,
we don't support resources
reference to other SML files.
Second, currently, the preview
window inside Andriod Studio
is using a display engine which
is different from the one used
in the Vector Asset Studio
dialogue and the build process.
While we are bridging the gap
between these two engines,
a good practice is
to use Vector Asset
Studio to import your asset
and keep the imported result.
Then, the generated PNGs
will be always the same
as you see doing
the import process.
Last, if you have to type
cast the drawable object
in your Java code, be aware
that on pre-Lollipop devices,
this drawable should be
cast as BitmapDrawable
instead of a VectorDrawable.
Also, set the
drawable's size properly
to make sure they
show up correctly
in the older versions.
With all this tools
update, I want
to thank all the
people who helped
to get this tool delivered.
And I hope you find
this as easier and more
pleasant to use VectorDrawable
in your application.
Please follow us on more
updates and improvements
in the near future.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]